[Music]
in bad life choices news submitted by
daddy of shrimps
that's our company a man is now disabled
for live after selling a kidney to buy
an iPhone what what you got and you gave
up your iPhone Bobby do you have an
iPhone or Android I have a iPhone now
okay cool why that's what you talking
now the thing is that just a real quick
Oh real quick is is that um Bobby set
off cameras I'm talking this whole
episode anybody broke that back no but
it says that you know I was staying
because I'm Korean and Samsung was
Korean yeah so I said to myself I'm
gonna stay Samsung for the rest of my
life yeah
it's more convenient to have an iPhone
because of my iPad and everything is the
link you know in all my movies and well
so that's all but that's exactly what's
good you did it
we'll see if he talks for the rest of
episode this man a Chinese man right but
she said Chinese he was like I have
something the same when Xiao Wang was
only 17 years old Wang Joey so he
decided to sell one of his kidneys in
order to buy the iPhone 4 oh no there's
way more now the hell you be what it is
oh god yeah so it was a status symbol in
his school and he wanted it but like his
poor family couldn't afford one so he
got in touch with some really shady
characters in his life and they
specialized in trading organs on the
black market and so they agreed to sell
one of his kidneys for twenty two
thousand one which is about three
thousand two hundred dollars I said for
a kidney yeah which is more than enough
to get the iPhone but so they obviously
lied to him and they said that he would
be complete he would be when I live a
completely normal life with just that
one kidney but because he went to any
legal hospital they did not sterilize
things properly
Oh what an infection and he did not tell
his family about this because again he's
17 she made a deal with the devil he
waited and waited and waited and like
his infection got worse and worse and
worse and it spread over to the other
like the kid only left kidney yeah and
so finally when he came cleaning his
family it was already too late they were
saying like the only way to survive is
to be on permanent dialysis and like now
he has to spend most of his life in bed
dependent on dialysis machine to keep
him alive but at the same time it's
shortening his lifespan by being on
dialysis and so his family was able to
track down the middleman that put him in
contact with the doctor and the
doctor who performed the surgery and
they were able to sue them and they came
down to 2.2 million yuan which is about
three hundred and twenty thousand US
dollars so that's all gonna be spent on
his treat oh gosh
now he's 24 years old can he buy another
kidney for $3,000 oh yeah yeah I mean
there's gotta be other kids not one I
thought how this is [ __ ] crazy
because we have a friend who has to
constantly be on dialysis right now
what does dialysis do it just so it
cleans your blood right because once
that when's your kidney fells you're
pretty much [ __ ] so you have to be on
dialysis I think he has to do it two or
three times a week yeah and it's like
twelve no for him it's almost every day
I think yeah cuz usually by the time you
get to like ten percent of kidney
function that's usually when people get
on dialysis but it must be even less
than that for him if he it's pretty bad
so he has to do it every day I think oh
yeah I got into 12 hours and then for
the rest of the time he's fine so we had
to do it during this sleep constant so
it's constant and there's such a high
risk to it dialysis like there's so many
things that could go wrong your blood
pressure could drop there's so many
things this is your blood leaving your
body and getting it filtered and clean
then coming back yeah so it's the blood
leaving going through a machine and then
getting put back in oh my god it's like
aquarium yes exactly that's exactly what
it is and when we had a I was having a
conversation with them he kind of says
like when when you're young you assume
that your body will just take care of
itself
yeah and then he just got progressively
worse and when there were signs that
things were going bad you're in denial
continue to ignore how old is he 33:34
so he has some like he's addicted what
food oh so he became type two diabetic
and then rendered himself rendered his
kidneys kidneys use it yeah which I
don't think he knew and then you know it
just got worse and worse and then he
just ignored everything and then lo and
behold how many types are there on
diabetes and
since if it is the job said there's
nothing to do with type 1 or type 2 it's
like a brain thing oh there's no type 3
though no are you sure I'm home you know
so much medical [ __ ] I went to nursing
school she's smart well I didn't want to
think you were stereotypes alright I
don't know what it is but everyone in my
family is a nurse I don't know any bad
Filipino stereotypes fashionable what's
about you just like yeah I guess the
Filipino time that's the only thing yeah
but that's like island time yeah so you
guys are chill okay they're emotionally
intelligent social yeah what the [ __ ]
we're talking about dumb stereotypes
that's too smart we don't know what the
[ __ ] that is because Korean people have
in Chinese people have been to these
people what's the what's the Filipino
bad stereotype no too much pork oh you
eat too much pork all your food is brown
like honey Bourdain said we had the best
roasted pig in the world our lettuce
even better than was electron Koala
koala is one type of it that was so
[ __ ] there's Letran [ __ ] Co if you
get the leftovers like when the electron
has already been eaten and you get
whatever is left on the bones the scraps
and you make this kind of like adobo
sauce in the morning it's always the day
I can cook all this but he doesn't like
to eat the home-cooked meal no Mike home
cook me i disgusting I was like
home-cooked meals damn he's not fighting
back you're gonna talk here to talk
Bobby needs dialysis dude listen how can
you like I do the daily vivacity you
rather have fried chicken
no keep growing up you know I had you
know white families around me hey come
on Bob come and eat there
you know I come over right and you can
put the napkin on your lap you know
there's utensils and they bring out some
sort of like pot of beef or whatever you
know what boiled beef why people you
know you'll pick up oil be even like
steamed vegetables of some sort right
it's never as good as like going to like
look at the bat-pole or something you
know you're saying no you you should
hurt spaghetti is the best spaghetti
I've ever had looking about but what I'm
saying is is that her cooking is great
but I'd rather go to bestir my palate
it's very sophisticated no it's not yes
it is you just said spaghetti factory he
thinks is like the best pasta stop stop
it stop okay it's fine
and also the manager's special with that
mushroom sauce and the moussaka cheese I
don't like olive are down really right
here WI only like spaghetti factor
because it has a nostalgia attached to
it okay yeah you're eating your
childhood I'm eating my childhood right
yeah thank you my friend thank you
that's I am with Irish sophisticated on
palate that's all no you don't you are
the least sophisticated well tell me why
cuz I eat Jersey Mike's I get the
Italian sub and add avocado and I also
add some jalapenos just a regular right
to split in half I like white bread
right in the chips and a diet coke
[Music]
yeah familiar with the food and it's on
the table like my first instinct is to
try it yeah yeah same thing is to say no
no no until I fight him and I force him
to taste like a child yes I never leave
my child my child does that that's me
well it's like this it's like she will
go to rest once you go have you trained
bone marrow like okay can I just say
because there's like cambodian style and
that [ __ ] just looks like dead carcass
but it's delicious I'm sure it's
delicious what's a Cambodian style
it comes in a big bowl yeah and it looks
like they get all of the bottom bones of
like the pho broth and they just throw
that [ __ ] in there and you pick at it it
looks like dog food like a bowl of dogs
it is good though it is good it's scary
looking but it's good yeah because let
me say this okay what if I was a caveman
and I hunted some a wildebeest right if
I acted the skin off right it's fully of
meat on the sides right
I would dry some you know I make the
paws and a little necklace right I took
the years you know mean make a little
you know toy out of for my kids I cave
kids you know okay and I will take the
bone I would give it to my dog there's
no way to look at a bone and go what's
inside it you chop it you go it's like
of this brown circle on the bone it
starts sucking in only white people said
let's boil it and see if we see that's
why I didn't want to talk this one cuz I
don't know I've never tried any of the
Koreans delicious that's actually yeah
it's a broken rice plate yeah anyway I
like good food
[Music]
do you not like you don't like ethnic
food I love ethnics men let me ask you
this song ethics or my favorite let me
ask you this so real quick though with
this guy right yeah so um you know the
status thing it's like you know growing
up my parents wouldn't get me things
they would give me something but some
things I wouldn't and in my head I'd be
like oh well I'll just if I don't like
because kids at my school some of them
were really rich and even I could have
Mercedes as well right and it's like and
I would get jealous and go look at the
nice clothes and the thing but you know
in my head I'm like I'm gonna you know
one day if I'll get it you know I work
hard and get one myself but I I can't
afford it and it's just not my thing
right now what kid why did he have to do
that why does he have to the pressures
of getting a stupid [ __ ] phone I mean
it's inside of your body it's crazy
pretty ambitious I mean if it worked out
it would have been a great plan if is if
you didn't get an infection it would he
would have lived a whole life good one
but what can I just do one show like I
do and get 20 [ __ ] gone is what
happened all right I mean I do one week
I work on my show I can get like a by
like 50 60 of them this humble ass brag
again dude imagine you're in high school
all right
imagine you're in high school in high
school Bobby doesn't doesn't look at
does it looks like this guy right oh
[ __ ] look at them look at them and then
and then and in high school Bobby sees
this this boy with the iPhone and five
girls go oh my god is that the iPhone 4
right and then any like yeah it is it is
the iPhone 4 and if you see that [ __ ]
he's like I gotta get I you're right
that's probably what happened power of
the [ __ ] and can I say something what I
just said earlier was just a joke and I
want to be humble about me doing one gig
an ATM that's not a Joe that's true you
know it was absolutely true a Tony for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]